we first went to UC Berkeley to talk to
students about us midterm elections
and now we're at Laney Community College
in Oakland California to ask them what
would it take for you to vote what would
it take for you to vote in the midterm
election I'm really not into all that
voting stuff I vote every time I just
don't think they expect young people
voting I don't think that one vote
really makes a big difference especially
being that where minorities I used to
read be registrar as a felon so wasn't
allowed to vote when this country began
not everybody could vote women couldn't
vote until 1920 I think if you can vote
then that's your responsibility to vote
as we talk more we got a sense of the
issues the students really cared about
promoting higher education it's so
expensive to go to school and not
everybody can afford to build health you
know I'm saying as opposed to building
wealth raising the minimum wage
gentrification ancient grains millet
economic inequality kale quinoa food
like that you know I'm a chef and that's
why I was focused on food thank you very
much how does it work Lexus police
brutality in the prison system came up a
lot if I have recognition that my police
brutality would be fixed immediately and
how everything's been going like in
Ferguson I want to feel secure in our
community put in my where I go prison
system police brutality I would like to
hear a candidate talk about that they
see that as an issue that they see it as
a problem most of the people who come
out of Oakland and San Francisco 18 and
over or people who are 18 and younger
actually they don't make it past
graduation at least give some of us a
fighting chance don't just throw us into
and especially if it's some of us who
like me it's a first offender I went I
went to UC Berkeley and I thought the
hell with students there and they didn't
have
my grades up and get there I hope you do
want more download the aj+ mobile app
and join the conversation available in
your App Store now